health experts are trying to raise
awareness about a life-saving technique
at everyone's finger pin prints tips
every year more than 350,000 Americans
suffer cardiac arrest when they're not
in a hospital only 12 percent survived
that's partly because fewer than half
receive CPR from a bystander chest
compressions alone no mouth-to-mouth
breathing needed could triple a person's
chance of survival in the critical
minutes before medical help arrives our
dr. Luke is here to show us how simple
this technique can be good morning so
you brought a friend here with you right
first of all what's his name and show us
how I need to have a name I didn't come
you caught me by surprise there so the
first thing that this is for teens and
adults okay and of course we encourage
people to have CPR courses but it's much
simpler than people realize
first of all how do you know that
somebody needs to have an intervention
CPR so the three C's the first C is
check check to see if they're responsive
check to see if the breathing is normal
if they're not responsive and the
breathing is not normal then there's
something serious going on the second C
is call call 9-1-1 once you start CPR
you don't want to stop it so you call it
yourself if there's somebody else there
call 911 the third C is compress chest
compressions so I'll do a little demo
here our friends at the American Red
Cross fantastic they actually gave me a
refresher course to make sure I was
going to be teaching it right they came
here and and brought mannequins so this
mannequin is here and you come here you
okay are you okay not responsive no
normal breathing so you start you take
the heel of your hand you put it in the
middle of the chest right about here you
intertwine your fingers you put your
shoulders over your wrists that's just
going to get a better position you lock
your elbows and then you start
compressing at about a hundred to 120
times a minute and you want to go about
two inches down give time for recoil and
you probably have heard that there's a
song that goes to about this beat if and
that is staying alive so staying just
like that stayin alive and you keep
going you do not stop until you get help
is that effectively jump-starting the
heart is that what the chest
compressions do it
so what is the heart to the heart is
beating and sending blood up the neck
and the carotid arteries to the brain
keeping the brain cells alive well after
about four to five minutes of not
getting blood the brain cells cells
start to die so the you want the heart
to beat by itself but if it's not
beating by itself you're beating for the
heart you're compressing it and you're
shooting that blood up into the brain so
why is the mouth-to-mouth no longer
necessary in this situation well if
you're an expert then we people still
have that as part of their armament area
because if you're not breathing if
there's some other problem then you do
want to have the full ability to do
breathing and compressions but it turns
out that for the average bystander if
somebody has cardiac arrest that's
350,000 times a year that it doesn't add
much to do the breathing and there's the
ick factor a lot of people if said they
just don't want to do it they don't want
to put their mouth on somebody else's
mouth and it turns out that it's pretty
much just as effective to do it in that
setting as if you you do the traditional
CPR quickly John can you hurt anybody by
doing rushing in and doing this no and
this is so important people are afraid
they're gonna somehow hurt somebody you
know and I got to tell you you can only
help in this situation I had a situation
a couple of years ago where somebody had
gone down they had cardiac arrest and
people were standing around even though
somebody knew how to do it they get
frozen and I got to tell you that I've
been in that position with the families
even if the person god forbid ends up
dying
they just feel okay at least the person
had a chance
they tried mmm all right John thank you
thank you interesting to learn more
about CPR go to our website CBS this
morning comm Jon LaPook you're still
with us because one other thing as
you've been teaching us about this new
type of CPR where should we go if we
want more information on our website
there is a fantastic 30-second video
hands-only dot NYC like new york city
hands only dot NYC dr. Holly Anderson
with my colleagues told me about it
they've prepared it in New York
Presbyterian please see it thirty
seconds and it goes over the whole thing
that's easy to do thank you